Hong Kong police have arrested and
charged two protesters for defying the
ban on wearing face masks during
demonstrations the protesters are the
first two people to be charged under the
new law outside the courthouse
supporters used umbrellas to protest the
Pro to protect the protesters identities
as they were ushered away the ban on
face masks has helped fuel days of
protests in Hong Kong tens of thousands
of pro-democracy protesters continued to
defy a ban on face masks on Sunday
Carrie Lam Hong Kong's chief executive
had introduced the ban under colonial
here a state of emergency powers to try
to end months of unrest pro-democracy
lawmakers again went to the High Court
on Sunday morning seeking an injunction
against the ban they argued the
emergency powers bypass the legislature
and contravene the city's Constitution
today is about authoritarianism versus
the rule of law I would say this is one
of the most important constitutional
cases in the history of Hong Kong but a
senior judge dismissed the case that
only increased the defiance of Hong Kong
residents large crowds marched through
torrential rain in unsanctioned rallies
Carrie Lam is trying to use the band to
keep us from coming out she's
suppressing our right to express
ourselves this will only push us further
as night fell things turned ugly some
demonstrators turning their rage on
businesses with connections to mainland
China and fighting pitched battles with
police Carrie Lam has warned that the
ban on face masks was only the first
card in her hand the emergency law
allows her to make any regulations
whatsoever in the face of this unrest
we're joined now by our correspondent in
Hong Kong
Matthias Berliner matthias the ban on
face masks has clearly angered the
protesters we saw violent clashes there
over the weekend what's happening there
today there are new protests announced
in in telegram groups and online forums
today so far they haven't started yet
but it's clear that the protesters want
to keep the pressure up they want to be
on the streets and the law has clearly
not achieved what it should achieve
according to the government to deter the
protesters and take some steam out of
the situation no now the protesters are
more furious than ever and everybody is
where almost everybody is wearing a face
mask now to the demonstration even those
that were not wearing any before but
Matthias we now have the police actually
arresting demonstrators two of them have
now appeared in court for wearing face
masks can we really expect that the
protesters will continue to defy the ban
on face masks
it's hard to say at the moment it looks
like this and if you look at what has
happening throughout these four months
then that's that every means of
deterrence be it troops at the border
with China threatening to enter the city
be it police tactics that target the
protesters at an early stage all this
has not worked so far the people are not
deterred and that might be because many
protesters fear that if they stop to
protest a much worse clamp down on the
city will happen and Beijing will take
its revenge so so far of course the
things are very volatile and and and can
take other turns but at the moment it
doesn't look like this is going to deter
the protesters they were not deterred by
long terms for rioting people were
charged with offenses that carry up to
ten years in prison so one year in
prison for wearing a mask will probably
not do the job either
I understand public transport in Hong
Kong has been severely disrupted Matias
how is that impacting daily life there
yeah you can see here this is one of the
major MTR stations one of the most busy
MTR stations in Hong Kong it has been
vandalized for several days in a row
half of the transport system is down
today again even more than half and of
course this makes life here very
difficult to transport system carries
five million passengers a day today is a
public holiday so people are not most
people are not commuting to their jobs
that is of course changing tomorrow when
schools and most businesses will pick up
again and we will see how this is going
to work of the city is built on this
transport system and it needs it adheres
thank you very much Matthias Berliner
there in Hong Kong